消えてしまうんだと 何もこんなところで何もつかまるものもないんだと
この方法では永遠というものは得られないということにすぐ納得してしまっちゃう
この納得する瞬間っていうのはすごい瞬間なんです
もう変わらない その人の心変わることは不可能なんです
ありのまま無常であることは見たんだから
それでも生きてきなさいと言ったっても
もうその人は二度とはもうやらない
もう悟れっていうのは
あるい他のすごい俗っぽい言葉で言えば
この無常についてもうもう納得してしまっちゃうんですね
それはただ もう私たちの納得と違って
もう修行してとくとんとくとんとくとん見たところで
徹底的に徹底的に自分の体の現象
心の現象を見て 見て 見て
見て 見て 心の欲を愛 渇愛を体験して
体験して それでも生きていきたい
それでも生きていきたい
自分の心の渇愛を体験して
何生きていきたいか 何で生きていきたいかと
見たらあるところで もう諦めようと
もう無常だからといっても
なんかすごい納得が それはパッとなんかもう瞬時に湧き上がるんですよ
予想しない瞬間で ただ嫌で嫌で
だいたいこの悟りの心が生まれる前に
結構間では人っていうのは徹底的に落ち込んでいるんです
この正真正銘の極力の落ち込みがあるんです
普通の人間には耐えられないんです
ですから 長い間修行して
しっかりした人間になって
しっかりしたもう性格があって
すごい力強い思いになって
その基本ができたところで
本当のものを見えてくるんですね
いわゆる恐ろしいものを見る前に
恐ろしいものを見ても大丈夫だという準備が必要なんです
何も準備していない時も
何も予想してないで いきなり恐ろしいものを見ちゃったら死んでしまっちゃいますから
で ですから そういう過程があって
そこでどんどん精神的にすごく優れて
集中力が抜群にあって
サマーディ状態も抜群にあって
もうやることない サマーディはあるわ
集中力はあるわ ヴィパッサナーちゃんとできるわ
物事は厳密に確認することはできるわ
わざわざ確認したっても
物事は勝手に見えてくるわ
ヴィパッサナーすごく優れて進んだところで
わざわざ確認しなくたっても
もう自分勝手に見えてるんです
それくらいしっかりしていたところで
もうやることないんですね
そこですごく落ち込むんです
あの落ち込みはこの世の中で誰にも直すことはできないんです
普通の人は絶対経験しない落ち込み
手も足も出ない状態で生きて生きていきたくない
死にたくもない で その瞬間で
その諦めの心が生まれる
だから予想できない まあ真面目に修行すると
まあだいたい客観的に観察するとだいたいわかりますけど
わかると言ったってもね
そんなことは厳密なことは言えないんですけど
まあ一応人の状態見るともうわかるんですよ
大体この落ち込み状態に入ってくる時
その時のこの人 ものすごい大事に守らなくちゃいけないんです
それもそろそろ悟っちゃいますからね
そこでも失敗しちゃったら
もうまた逆戻りというか
また初めからやり直す
誰か来て誘惑しちゃったら
まあじゃあそれだったらそんなことやめてね
もう食べて飲んで遊ぼうかとね
ああそうね それやろう
じゃああとまた暖かくなってきた
究極のレベルまで高くなった心は
またこうなっちゃいますけど
まあヴィパッサナー経験はもうなくなりませんだけど
この何て言いますか このせっかくした準備が効いちゃうんですね
例えば スポーツで何か投げるでしょ？なんかこのこうやって回って回って回って遠くのあれ何投げ？投球
そういう 遠くを投げるためには
こうやって体の力を全部集中して
それで体の力 手を通してそのハンマーの先っぽまで
いや 怒るでしょ 怒って作って最後にこれ以上自分に力がないという瞬間で投げるんですね
そうすると遠くへ行くんですね
そこでこうやって投げて
どうなるんですか そうすると
また初めからやり直しなんですね
だからって その人 今までやったスポーツの訓練とか
それは無駄になったわけではないんです
それは何回 何回やり直さないと
もうどうしても投げられ投げられなくなっちゃうんですね
ですから その失敗だけしないならばもう大丈夫ですけどね
ですから このヴィパッサナーでは
こういう そういう風な
この心のヴィパッサナーは一応終わった
終わってからさらに訓練しちゃうと
この状態が出てくるんです
もう徹底的にこの変化していって
無常・滅・苦・生滅変化がどんどん見えてきて
どんな落ち込んじゃってもやる気が消えちゃっても
徹底的にもう 恐怖感 嫌な気持ち
わかりやすく言えば もう極限の落ち込む
もう絶対的なもう存在の究極的な落ち込みみたいなものが出てきて
それでなんか瞬間にもう心がもう変ちゃう
それで今までの落ち込みはなんか嘘のように消える
それからその人は別に感激することもなく
落ち込むこともなく ものすごく落ち着いて
それはこの諦め 最初の諦め
もう無常やと もう追っかけなくてもいいやと
求めなくてもいい それからはその人は求めないんだから
生きてきた生きてよということはもう消えちゃったんだから
もう聖者の流れに入ったんですね
もうその人だけ自然的に進化するんです
もう進化する方向違い道がない
その人に堕落はなし ですから
確実に進化の道に入ったという意味でソーターパッてよる道と言うんです
そういうわけで このよる道心という心がほんの瞬間の心
1時間怒る心じゃないんです
我々は怒り 怒りで 1時間って嫉妬で 2時間とかやるんだけど
もう心ってのは瞬間ですからね
夜同心っていうのは一番大事な心なのに
ほんの瞬間一回しか会われないんです
でもその瞬間で この 編み物みたいな
この存在の結んでるあれは解けちゃうんです
それでただ引っ張れば全部解けてしまっちゃうんです
編み物で何かね 編んでしまっちゃったら
最後に結び目入れちゃうでしょ
それでしっかりしているんですね
布とかって あの結び目を掠っちゃえば
もう引っ張っ 全部抜けてしまっちゃう
全部消えちゃう ですから
あの瞬間 そういう瞬間なんです
そういうことで 悟りというのはもう確実なもので
もう間違いはありませんね
そこには 体験した人は知っているんであって
他の人は誰も知らない
よる それは日本語で預流道と読むんですね
ソーターパティ・マグガチッタは預流道という
この預流道の心が生まれたら
それは悟りの心 次の瞬間でか
瞬間に瞬間一つ二つ経ったところでも
このソーターパティ・パルチッタが生まれるんです
預流果心が生れるんです
預流道 預流果と すぐ生まれるんです
で 本当のところは別に道とかにこんなややこしく区別しなくてもいいんですよ
こんな瞬間だから でもヴィダルマではきめ細かく分けてるんです
例えば諦めちゃうでしょ
あの瞬間で 今までの輪廻の中で一生懸命やってきたこのことをやめましたと
諦めた瞬間に次にほっとするんですね
あ なくてもいいやと こんなことやらなくてもいいやと
そのほっとする心は預流果なんです
それは本当の涅槃の味わいなんです
ですから 預流道心が生まれたら
次に預流果心が生まれる
その生まれた瞬間で また普通の瞑想の心に戻るんです
心が 瞑想の普通のヴィパッサナー瞑想の心に戻るんです
ヴィパッサナー瞑想の心に戻っても
ものすごい落ち着いているんですね
そこで自分の心に何が起きたかと
なんかすごい雷を打ったようなことになったんだけど
なんか全部もう全部壊れてしまったととわかるんですね
あれ 自分には何が起きたかと
自分をちょっと観察しちゃうとか
そういうのは自然的に起こるんです
あ それでああ なるほど
こういうことになったんだと
というふうに納得して
それで瞑想は 1段階終了と
もう崖戻りしない もう聖者の世界に入って
聖者の境地の一人になっていて
その人は進化の過程に入っていて
もうそれからいくら怠けても進化する
それからは いくら怠けてふざけていたっても
心は進化する それは止まれません
それはこの宝経ですか
宝経を読んでみてください
全部宝経では偈二つ以外は全部この預流道の聖者の心の境地を書いているんです
この宝経っていうのは
このヴィサーラ国町がこのいろんな悪霊たちにさいなまれて
この乾季状態で大変苦しんでいた時
乾季状態で飢えてひどい
それから伝染病とかあった時は
お釈迦様がこの祝福として教えたお経だというんですね
お釈迦様がヴィサーラ国町に入ったその瞬間で
ものすごい大量に雨が降って乾季状態に入ったんですし
で 聖者でも来てもらえば我々の不幸は消えるだろうと
確実にそうなった それで人の心も清らかにしてあげなくちゃいけないし
いろいろ悪い霊が悪いエネルギーが入っちゃいますからね
悪いところに それは取り出さなくちゃいけないんだから
こういうお経をお釈迦様はアナンダ尊者に教えたんです
あなたはこのお経をあげて街を祝福しなさいと
お釈迦様やらなかったんです
アナンダ尊者は阿羅漢になってないんですね
お釈迦様のお世話ばっかりやってもう毎日忙しいんですね
で もう預流果にはなっていたんだからね
お釈迦様は別にもう焦らないし
アナンダ尊者も違うこといろいろ勉強したい
修行したいって気持ちはあっても
お釈迦様やらせないんですね
あんたこういうのをやりなさい
あれやりなさいとかね
それでもそばにいて欲しかったみたいですね
2人はすごくもう仲が良かったんだから
ですから アナンダ尊者に頼んで
こういうお経をあげて祝福しなさいと
そこはストーリーはどうでもいいんですけど
僕はこのなぜアナンダ尊者がそこに出るかということと
この経の内容を読んでみると
ブッダの力が言ってるのはもう 3箇所
法の力のことを言っているのは 2箇所
サンガの力言ってるのは全部残りは
その中でも阿羅漢たちに使っているのはたった 1偈だけ
大量に残るにも結構長い
何行あるんですかね あれはわかりません
数えてない 数えてないんだけど
全部預流果の人のことを言ってるんです
ですから 預流果の人の心の力ですか
聖なる力で祝福しているような感じなんです
そこはなんで預流果のこと
そこまで言ってるかというと
もしかすると実際にアーナンダ尊者がそれをやったかもしれません
実際に そうすると自分の自分でわかるんですね
お経をあげると 自分の心の気持ち言ってるんだから
いくら怠けたって堕落することないんですよ
ああだこうだとかありますから
よく本人の気持ちが祝福するために
よく理解した上で 本人の気持ち
心のエネルギーがものすごく姿勢に絞っちゃう
絞られるんですね お釈迦様
偉大なるブッダの力のことばっかり喋ってても
アーナンダ尊者ってさっぱりわからないでしょうね
そうすると気持ちの集中できないんですね
阿羅漢たちの心のお経を書いたならば
アーナンダ尊者でもさっぱりわからない
ですから 預流果の境地を変えて教えて祝福しなさいと
よく考えたもんですよ
そういうのは 祝福する場合は
やっぱり気持ちはちゃんと整えてないと伝わらないんです
ですから 僕らもたまに人々を祝福したりはするんだけどね
たまに相手方の態度が悪くて
なかなかこのもう心の集中できないんですね
そうすると本当にもう祝福したくないんですね
だから無駄な時間で 自分がお経文句を言うのは言うんだけど
何の効き目がないんですね
向こう側の受信機がね
整えちゃうと もう時間もかからないし
ちょっと二 三分ででも終わっちゃうし
そこで抜群に効くんです
一時間 二時間とか一晩とかね
お経あげたっても 向こうは全くもう態度が変わってるなら
もうどうしようもないんです
そこはまた脱線ですね
で 預流果になるとどうなるかと
預流果になった人が初めて無常を感じるんですね
無常を認める 無常であることは
無常と戦わない 永遠になろうと
ですから その人 その方だけ
初めてこの煩悩なくなっちゃうんですね
このサッカーヤ・ディッティという煩悩が消えちゃうんですね
日本語ではこれ有身見と言うんですね
このサッカーヤと書くんだけど
これは 元々の言葉は SAT のサットなんですね
サット それからカーヤ
それからディッティ サットというのはこのインド文化系の全ての宗教で使っている言葉で
このリアリティ 実体という意味で
いわゆる魂がを意味するんですね
カーヤは心であってボディ
ボディなんですね ボディっていうのはもう身体という意味ではなくて
まあ英語でも例えばリーガルボディというでしょ
あれ 法律体系っていう意味なんですね
法律的な体があるわけじゃないんだから
システムというふうな何かの体系ですから
このサットという何か実体として何か体系でできているという意味なんですね
そのディッティ そういう考え方
それはインドにある全ての宗教にある教えなんですね
基本的にどんな宗教であろうとも
何かここにあるんだと
システムが 心たるシステムがあるんだと
それは宗教では一般的なもの
いわゆる皆様にそんな専門用語ではなくて
一般の言葉で言えばわかりますから
一般的に言えば これは私が
私たるものはあるんだという考え方なんですね
私の中に私たるものは
いわゆる真の私いるんだという
いると思っているんです
いると思ってて その真の私は誰ですかとわかってないだけで
そこで修行するんですね
真の私を目指して いわゆる真我を目指して修行するんです
それは仏教じゃないんです
そこで修行してヴィパッサナーすると無常を見れる
無常しかないことを見える
それに渇愛から私がいたがるという概念が生まれるということを見えてくる
そこで全部無常や何な馬鹿なことをやってるんだったというふうな感じの頭の何かもう消えてしまうんですよ
今まで何やってたんですかと
その瞬間で この これは真我でもいいし
有身見でもいいし 私たるもの
私で私という何かあるというディッティ
見 邪見はもう消えちゃう
それ消えるということは智慧なんですね
それは理解だから 我々今誤解しているでしょ
世の存在を 誤解を解いちゃったんだから
また二度と誤解は生まれませんでしょ
瞑想はもうやらないともう堕落するんです
集中力はもう毎日やらなきゃもうどうせもう堕落しちゃうんですね
でも理解は消えないでしょ
別に 小さい時は我々は 1 たす 1 は 2 だと教えてもらったし
そこは別に苦労しなくても
いくらふざけたっても
1 たす 1 は 2 ということは知ってるんだから
理解っていうのはそういうもので
もう消えることはない
経験ですからね 自分の経験だから
それはもう ですからもう
もう もう他の悟りは 例えばパズルを持ってくる
このパズルを解いてください
といったら 初めは分からなくて分からなくて
無茶苦茶かもしれませんだけど
やがて分かってしまっちゃう
こうやってこうやってこうやれば OK やと
それまた分からなくなったっていうことはないでしょ
一旦できたら 一旦できたらもうできるんですね
そういうもので 一旦無常やということを無常ですよということを理解すれば
もう逆戻りは全くない
また馬鹿に この前知識人でしたけど
今日は馬鹿になってそんなことはないんです
知識のある人はいくら馬鹿げてふざけても知識人でしょう
サッカー出て有身見という煩悩が消える
皆様方 大体煩悩煩悩って言ってすぐ思い浮かぶのは欲やら怒りやらとかね
まあ嫉妬やら そういうとこですけど
そういうとこはそんなに心配しなくてもいいんです
まず頭しっかりすることが大事なんですよ
嫉妬とかいくらあってもいいんだけど
それは性格が汚いんだからね
性格ぐらい立派に見えてもらわなくちゃね
まあどうしようもないんだから
まあ立派な人間としての生きるために必要なぐらい
怒りも嫉妬も混乱も競争心も抑えておいて
だからって根元から消そうというのは
そんなもうことはもうちょっと置いといて
もう素晴らしい人間だと
本当にできた人やという風に
自分からでも他人からでも言われるようなぐらいは抑えておく
完全に欲捨てる必要はないんです
で まあ欲があったってもほどほどに
相手が自分何かすごく頑張って欲しくて
まあいいや 持ってきてくださいと
で 向こう側が物はね まあ一万円で売ろうとしていると
一万円は高すぎだから
じゃあなんとか五千円
五千円で買ってもらおうとかね
そういうふうなことでは別に
私は欲がないんだから
一万円？じゃあはいはいと
それはバカバカらしいことよね
ですから そういうことじゃなくて
誰かが何か悪いことしたら
これはすぐ怒ったとかね
ああ やっぱりけしからん
けしからん そこはもうもちろんね
悪いこと言っちゃったら怒りますからね
でも怒って散々怒りを持って
嫉妬を持って それはないんですね
あ 怒った まあ怒りましたから
まあそれでも後で落ち着いて
その時は怒りました その人とまた次また仲良くしたりとかね
それぐらいの性格でいいんです
悟りの場合は 一番必要なのは
その煩悩が消える前に
依然この思考 物事正しく見ろと
物事正しく見えないことは煩悩の一番目なんです
欲じゃないんです 怒りではないんです
で サッカーで言ってみる
次に消える煩悩は 当たり前で消えちゃうんです
もう次から次に サッカリと打ち切っちゃう
打ち切っちゃうっていうのは疑い
疑いと書く場合の漢字使います
疑ですね この煩悩見たってすごい視線的で簡単に消せるような煩悩でしょうに
怒りとか嫉妬とか全然出てこない
疑は消える 疑はいろいろ疑いがあるんだけど
この状態で我々疑というのはちょっと違う意味で疑と言うんです
私はこの疑の説明をすると
いろんな次元で説明します
これはもう最終的な次元だから
この時にだけ限って 普通の注釈書とかなんとかことこと出てくる定義当てはまるんですね
これでは何に疑かというと
過去現在未来に対する疑い
因果法則に対する疑い
仏道に対する疑い 仏道っていうのはこの修行法
そういう何種類かな 何種類かこのテキストであるでしょうと思いますけどもね
何種類書いてますか？ブッベ・カンガティ・アバランティ・カンガティ・ブッバ・アバランティ・カンガティ・サンパッティ
取ってください こちらにいます
で パーリ語で直接直訳すると
ちょっと ちょっと日本語でなんか
なんか理解しにくいところあります
大体この過去・現在・未来ということは
すごい仏教における時間論でしょ
人間の過去・現在・未来概念というのは仏教では認めてないんです
過去があるか 未来があるかとかね
過去があるためには未来が現在がなければ
現在が存在しなければ未来あるわけでもない
そんな相対的なことであるんだ
ないんだ あるんだ ないんだと
もう勝手にしろと もう時間論なんかはね
何の意味もないんです
私は過去にいたんですか？とかね
今いるんですか？とか
将来いるんですか？とか
将来私にはどんな存在ですか？とかね
そういういろいろ問題
頭の中にいっぱいあるんです
でももう全部消えちゃう
もうわかる もうわかった
なぜならば これは全てはもう瞬間瞬間無常であると
幻想だけであると その時
それ一時的に何か 何か原因
ちょっとまとめて何かできただけのことで
それ消えちゃう そこにまた他の条件があります
また何か出てくるだけで
そこにもう時間論が成り立たなくなっちゃうし
ですから 今まで世の中にあるありとあらゆるものについて
もうすべての疑いは消える
それから修行に 宗教について
じゃあ宗教にするならば
世の中ではどんな宗教が正しいのかと
その人になった初めて仏教は正しいとわかるんです
今はそこまではないんです
預流果になって初めて仏教の信者さんなんです
そこまでは人間の心は信頼できません
いくら一生懸命真面目にやっても信頼できません
どう変わるかわかりませんから
ということは この 無常を見させてくれたんだから
本当に見方を教えてくれたし
それで自分がもう悟ったし
それでわかるのは無常を見なきゃ悟れないということなんですね
そこでキリスト教の宗教において
その天国は正しい天国か
ヒンドゥー教でおっしゃっている梵天が正しい天国かどうか
そこを困ったなとか 極楽道は正しいところかどうか
それは困りますよ もう向こうは極楽道に行ってくださいという
ある人は天国に行ってくださいと
ある人は梵我一如になってくださいという
どっちに行けばいいかなと困りますし
じゃあ 3つも同じではないかなと
またすごい楽な考え方出てくるんですね
例えば 3つも極楽道の概念も
天国の概念も 梵我一如の概念も同じだったら
同一のものだったら楽でしょ
それみんな同じだ どんな宗教も同じだという大馬鹿者も大怠け者もいるんですよ
本人が知識的に喋ってると思ってるんだけどね
あれは大怠け者なんです
便利で どんな宗教も同じ境地目指してるんだとかね
冗談じゃないんで それだったらそんなたくさん宗教要りませんだからね
それぞれ解釈は違うし
道が違うし 修行方法は違うし
説明は違うし 同じじゃないんです
ですから どちらがいいかわからないし
困っちゃうし 悟った人はもうわかっちゃうんですね
もう生きていきたいとどこら頑張ったっても意味がないんだと
極楽道に行っても 梵我一如になっても
天国に行っても まあそれは単なる生存欲であって
無常は知らないんだからそうなるだけであってということで
初めて今まで自分が実践してきた実践方法は正しいと
やっぱり釈迦さんの道
この道は ああなるほど
自分体験したんだから正しいとわかっちゃう
ですから すべての疑いは消えると
しっかりする それきり
それからは もう中途半端な人生じゃない
物事はしっかり判断できるし
しっかりするし もういわゆる私の個人的な言葉で言うならば
本物の徹底した究極的な哲学者になるということなんです
何でももう透き通って見られる
で 何の疑いもないんだから
でも疑いないで それはすごい大胆なことでもないんです
この私がいるかいないかとか
過去があるかいないかとか
ヴィパッサナーはいいか
それぐらいでもう消えちゃうっていうぐらいでね
だからこの有身見消えちゃったら当然疑いが消えるんです
全然頑張らなくてもいいんです
有身見さえカットすれば
ついでに 技能煩悩も消える
セット それはもう過ぎています
次に消える煩悩は 次の煩悩は長いんです
シーラッバタ・パラマーサという煩悩
その煩悩も消える シーラ
シーラは戒 これでBのB一つ取っちゃって BATA
ばかり これワタでもいいんですけど BATA
でも ワタというのは行
いろんな行 儀式 行 シーラは戒
いろんな戒め ワタはいろんな行
パラマーサっていうのはもう徹底的に
何て言いますか なんとか言葉言うんですね
徹底的に自分が捕まって
これこそやという風な
この熱意 このこの道でやるぞというふうな
この しがみこんでいる状態なんです
ある生き方に ある戒律に
もうしがみこんで 私はこれを殺してももうやめませんと
殺されても 固執 固く執着していること
それはこの大体我々の心の根底にあるんです
で 一番これ悪口かもしれませんだけど
世の中の人間っていうのは本当に怠け者で
よくもうふざけて食べて
もうのんびりやってるでしょ
気持ちとしては 本当はまあよく美味しく食べて
よく寝て遊んで生活したいんですね
やってるんだけど 逆に口先で修行っていうのは立派なもんですねとかね
って言うんです そこで誰かが千日行やったとかね
あるいは 10 年間山なんとか行やったとかね
あるいは火の行は10 年間続けてやったとかね
ある人はもう 5 年間立ち禅やっていたんだとか
インドにいますよ 立ちっぱなしの禅人たちとかね
座らない で 何年も経ちますから
もう足が汚くなって もう膨らんじゃって
それでももう行やってるんです
それ見るとみんな素晴らしいんだ
素晴らしいんだ これこそ素晴らしい真面目な行者とか
あれほど真面目にやってるんだから
みんな大勢に行って その人を拝んだり
ふやかしたりするんですね
その行を好きな気持ちは
この怠け者に限って徹底的にあるんです
で まあ僕も本当にもう笑っちゃいますけど
そこで誰かの 例えば出家の人が
出家ではなくて 宗教の人が普通にみんなとちょっと喋ったり
ちょっと遊んだり いろいろことをやったり
一般的に普通にごく普通の生活をすると
なんであの人 とはもう何やったら生臭臭ではないかとかね
あの神父さんがもうまあまあ本当に遊んでいて
もう全然もう真面目じゃないんだと
私は信頼しませんよとかね
否定する そこである神父さんがもういつ見たってもロザリオを持ってもうやってるならば
もういつでも会っても
もう十字架の前でなんと祈りしているとかね
あるいはボロ服を着ていて
素晴らしいと言うんです
どうやってそれを知ってるんですかね
それはどういうことかというと
この怠ける人々が自分の気持ちから判断するとありがたく見えちゃうんです
自分がやらないんだから
ですから その傾向はどんな人間にもあります
なぜならば どんな人間でも正直に言うと怠けたいでしょう
怠けたくないというのは嘘でしょうし
どんな人間でも腹いっぱい食べて
だいたいみんなこのいろいろダイエットなんかしているんだけど
気持ちはどうですかね
美味しいものは食べたいでしょうに
気持ちは美味しいものを食べて
もうちょっとお腹でも上を向いて寝たいという気持でしょうね
ですから まあそれは本当の心の状態で
ですから そこから見ると
食べない人はありがたく見える
いろいろ葉っぱとご飯だけ食べてる人を見ると
ああ 素晴らしいな 私もああいう風にやりたいなとか思ったりするし
この人は本当に自分をコントロールしているぞと誤解する
なぜならば 自分は自分にコントロールできないでしょ
そういう風に この表で見える戒律と儀式行などにある未練
人間持っている未練 それはすべての生命持っています
ある特定の人間だけではなくて
すべての生命は それを煩悩だからみんな同じなんです
私はいくらこんなことを言っても
ここでもっとこの行者らしく見える他のお坊さんがいて
服の衣の色も行者らしく
もっとこの黒い色に近づけとかね
あるいはあっちこっち破れているとか
髭が私より伸びたりとかね
で 骨もいくらか見えたりとかしてると
皆様が礼をすると 誰に先に礼をするかというと
その人に先にする 誰が年上かどうかね
ということじゃないんです
誰が心育てるかではなくて
見た目で見てやっちゃうんです
それはもう誰でも同じなんです
私はそれすごくニコニコ笑って見ているんです
だいたい私は出家する経験長いんだからね
たまにもう三味みたいに三味なんですけど
自分と一緒にいろいろ何かもう助けて欲しくて
何か教えてもらいたいとか
誰かが人は来る 来たらその人に一生礼をして礼をして
それからあなたもうるさいな
もう人いるんだから礼をしなくてという感じでやるんですね
だから心の中でね こいつはこのガキに俺をしたって何にもないのに
やっぱりってわかるんですね
で そういう 何て言います
それはそのある特定の人がおかしいではなくて
それはどんな生命でもそんなもんなんです
戒律と行に固執 固く執着しているんです
だからと自分がやってますけど
全然ない やってないんだから
この怠け癖あるんだから出てくる煩悩なんです
怠け癖ない場合はもうバカにしちゃうんです
例えば山を登ったりする
自分にでもやればできるんだ
だから何ですかと という状態ですね
あまり評価しない ある人はアルプス登ったと
登れない我々はすごいと思っちゃうんですね
毎年登る人はそうなんだ
それぐらいでしょ ですから
こういう大勢を褒めるのは
自分にはそういうことはないんだから逆なんですから
歌えない人は ある人が上手に歌うと驚く
すごい上手に歌を歌える人は
もう一人の人は上手に歌ったんだからといって別になんとも思わない
代わりに何かケチを付けるかもしれません
もうちょっと感情を出した方がいいんじゃないかとかね
もう発音がもうちょっとしっかりした方がいいんじゃないかとか言うかもしれません
それでまたこの怠けの方々は
この人は嫉妬しているんだとかね
なんで人を批判して あんなほどあれほど素晴らしく歌っているのにとか言うかもしれません
でもその それは違いますよ
まあとにかくこの全ての生命に
ですからもう怠け癖というのがありますから
誰にでも この戒やら行やら
そういうものには固執
固く執着するということがあります
そこでこの方が瞑想して
すごい衝動を持って瞑想して
ありのまま物事を見てみたところで
身体と心のコンディションが素晴らしく
最高な時に限って瞑想を進んだことも知っているし
この覚った気持ちも覚ったという出来事も
心と体のコンディションが一番いい時に起きたものだから
それで心が清らかになったんだから
治ったんだから